americans
americans annoy me more than other
foreigners though i would say
that's on camera oh
why why do you why do americans annoy
you than any other foreigner um very ex
the okay the ones in japan at least a
lot of the ones that complain about
being in japan like i hate japan oh
they're so racist or no one wants to sit
on sit next to me in the bus
and they just had this horrible
experience in japan and they're mostly
i'm not saying all english teachers are
like this but a lot of times they are
english teachers who are
being they stay as english for years and
they dream of being in a different
position or different job yeah yeah but
they're just like all this i hate japan
america is the best but like why don't
you go back to america
but they don't and yeah so that's why
english teacher in japan seems like hell
did they complain more than us
yeah
wow wow different type of complaints
though okay and they're usually
generally very negative
when i complain i'd like to think you
know i very much understand where a lot
of them come from but off camera you
guys are always praising how amazing
japan is like don't don't tell them
that's our entire brand's valentine oh
my god wow
the absolute slander we're not going to
praise japan a lot of cameras not praise
but like you guys seem to be enjoying
genuinely we i mean that's why we're
here right yeah that's because we enjoy
being here yeah this positive energy
here in the uk what would i do in the uk
yeah yeah oh hey guys gonna go to a bar
there's different countries gonna go to
a pub and uh i'm pretty good and
tomorrow i'm gonna go to another pub
yeah
you know for all the slander i've given
it if i did have to move anywhere i'd
probably go to america
really really probably living in a
country you weren't born and raised in
is fun it doesn't matter yeah i just
want to yeah it's stimulating i'd love
to live in america for a short period of
time because i'd like to live in europe
really i live in europe i'd like to live
somewhere else in asia probably just i
don't know i just i just really vibe
with asian culture and asian mentality
that's that's good i mean not that we
have any plans for movies yeah yeah just
just hypothetically hypothetically if
you were like connor you have to get out
of japan you're being deported which
country do you want to move to i'll go
to america for a bit what do you
consider when you want to move to
another country is it like the weather
i'll give a [ __ ] about the wildlife for
me it's about like whether i just vibe
with the way of living with the culture
opportunities as well like
as much as i like america i personally
don't think i could vibe with the
american way of life just personally
yeah what is the american way of life i
don't know it's just like it's just like
i cannot be a great american
[Music]
you would i think i'd be a [ __ ] i
think you would i don't know like i like
going to america i like american friends
you know i like you know being in
america when i visit but like yeah when
i envision myself living in america i
just don't see it
i don't know what it is it's just a vibe
like like as as as you like whatever you
realize that sometimes you just like
subconsciously jive with some things and
like there's there's a difference going
there
for holiday and actually living there
and i think we've all experienced this
in japan where coming here on holiday
visiting here and actually experiencing
and living the culture here is totally
different what do you do maylin spilled
some tea on the wall some tea and then i
forgot to swallow and then it was going
to spew out so it was having a crisis
no i think it's some tissue it's fine it
was it landed on my shirt i agree though
i mean you know i find that socially i
in america sometimes i'm just like
utterly confused yeah well i just don't
understand the person i'm talking to
yeah because i'll just say things and
i'm like why would you say that
in the uk though i don't really get that
there's like a script almost everyone
follows yeah which is kind of boring
though at the same time but it's coming
it sounds like it gets monotonous though
right yeah you know when you go to
america it's always interesting like you
never have a dull moment it's i feel
like i'm very easy to approach and
you're also an extrovert right yeah i
guess sir like for me whenever i go back
to america japan has like
made me more of an introvert so when i
go orders food and then the registered
person is like how are you doing oh like
trying small talk i'm just like please
just stop talking to me
i just want my burger stop talking to me
and then i start sweating and then i
hate that but then you would love that
because you know you like the minimum
direction because for me like that kind
of stranger friendliness that you get
from americans in america i've
experienced 20 pluses of that in
australia yeah so it's like no different
to me it's just it's just oh you have a
funny thing because i i i it's so far
from everything
i mean yeah also everything wants to
kill you what the food is so delicious
yeah you are frothing over this oh
if you're saying the food's delicious
then
i gotta check this out how many google
reviews did you do you can't like
we didn't have that much time yeah how
hard is it to get good internet in
australia it's i've gotten a lot better
in the past like since i've moved out
okay okay like if you go to like
melbourne or sydney like they actually
have
good internet speeds now finally after
all this time of course they had to do
it right when i [ __ ] left the country
honestly like i i think i could really
jive with the australian culture
i just it's so far from everything every
everyone is at least a 12-hour flight
minimum from you it is well like how how
often do these australians love
traveling yeah yeah
exactly right
australians like [ __ ] everywhere
especially in asia yeah you're [ __ ]
rid of them
san diego apparently oh they're invading
san diego apparently really yeah why san
diego i don't know one of a few of my
san diego friends are like there's so
many australians here she says after
meeting one
australian when i was growing up though
i i always thought america was way
cooler than the uk i just thought i
think that's just because you were born
to be fair growing up i thought pretty
much anywhere else was cooler than the
uk the uk right
you know
our image is on borrowed time yeah what
the uk actually is and what people think
the uk is is entirely different it's
starting to catch up with us now in our
lifetime if while when i was on the when
i was growing up everyone still thought
that brief people were like charming and
sexy yeah
everyone's like oh my god he's british
oh my gosh oh you know and then now it's
like tuesday bottle of water that's all
i get man and that's what i always
just get now we just get clowned on by
everyone including us because i'm just
like no no no we clown on ourselves you
can't clown on us you know the uk is uh
has very picturesque things it's very
nice and elegant things but uh
unfortunately it's um
stones
i mean the bricks
breaks the bricks the buildings i love a
lot of materials oh like the stone
buildings
i love a lot about architecture
there we go there it is
you know zooming in on the image of just
one of the bricks right like a stone
wall a single brick yeah and i was like
uk has nice bricks it was nice it was
nice the uk was nice i feel like it's
kind of it's gone downhill a lot yeah
since the old sheep running through the
fields the good old days
not the days where i was born for me it
looked like it was pretty cool i don't
know if that's because i wasn't born
there yet but yeah
maybe i don't know i i i feel like i
feel like some things were just cooler
before we were born i feel like you know
the stereotype about you know music was
better in my parents days or you know
when your parents said that i think
that's actually kind of true i think i
think i would love to have lived in my
parents age with some of the [ __ ]
bands and stars that they love at the
same time yeah but at the same time you
think about it it's like all right well
there's no internet uh there's no iphone
yeah or anything like that like
that sounds pretty crappy honestly when
you think about it like now that you
know the you know the whole
you live handiness of today you live you
know you
assimilate with whatever you have at the
time right you get used to yeah so yeah
of course of course
even if you had no phone you'd get it
but do you think like you know kids 30
40 years from now will be saying the
same thing about no no no no i mean the
uk the roaring 20s it's very unfortunate
because i feel like they coming from
like up north like every or everything
in the uk was kind of like focused on
london in the south and there's the
common sentiment from where i grew up
and around the area is that like which
kind of like abandoned and all the money
and stuff and all the investment went to
like london so a lot of the a lot of the
northern cities in the uk kind of like
been like deprived of any economical
advantages or anything and so a lot of
the cities are kind of getting run down
it's not very it's kind of like japan
isn't it yeah oh very much so but
unfortunately it's like i feel like at
least in the countryside of japan it's
like all right well at least they can
still do the local business of farming
and stuff in some certain uk towns just
nothing there's like nothing to do how
do you make money in the those areas
it's all like
it's all like minimum wage jobs and
there's no like big business there or
you commute to the bigger city yeah yeah
yeah i mean i was thinking about this
earlier and i think we i i think as we
grow older we will be able to say that
we did grow up in a pretty cool time
actually because we have like i was
thinking like what would be interesting
to like a younger generation to hear
about and i think the fact that we grew
up in the age where basically internet
was invented yeah i think that would be
cool i think that'd be cool
generation of like people really who
grew up
initially without a smartphone yeah yeah
it wasn't like until like age
what like 13 i think yeah
like imagine saying to your grandchild
you know let me let me tell you when the
internet just was assimilated into
society yeah i'm just like i think
that's a cool [ __ ] story because i
grew up in the [ __ ] vcr dvd era right
yeah yeah just like ancient technology
the kids today like they're like wait
what what the [ __ ] like kids they don't
know what a vcr is i'm like have i
really gotten to that point now where
i'm just like oh you [ __ ] youths of
today don't even know what a vcr is you
never had to like stick the pencil in to
like rewind the tape and just let me let
me tell you about limewire and napster
let me tell you the war stories of how
we download how to download lincoln
webster
had to download linkin park and got
[ __ ] bill clinton for the 50
millionth time